we're told that triangle abc has
perimeter p and in radius r and then
they want us to find the area of abc in
terms of p and r so we know the
perimeter is just the sum of the sides
of the triangle or how long a fence
would have to be if you wanted to go
around the triangle and let's just
remind ourselves what the n radius is if
we take if we take the angle bisectors
of each of these vertices each of these
angles right over here so bisect that
right over there and then bisect that
right over there this angle is going to
be equal to that angle
this angle is going to be equal to that
angle and then this angle
angle there and the point where that
those angle bisectors intersect that
right over there is our in center and it
is equidistant from all of the three
sides and the distance from those sides
that's the in radius
so let me draw the in radius so when you
find the distance between a point and a
line you want to drop a perpendicular so
this length right over here is the in
radius
radius and this length right over here
is the in radius and if you want you
could draw an in circle here that at
with the center at the in center and
with radius r and that circle would look
something like this we don't have to
necessarily draw it for this problem so
you could draw a circle that looks
something like that and then we'd call
that the in circle
so let's think about how we can find the
area here especially in terms of this in
radius well the cool thing about the n
radius is it looks like the altitude or
this looks like the altitude for this
triangle right over here triangle a
let's label the center let's call it i
for in center
so the r is the this r right over here
is the altitude of triangle aic this r
is the altitude of triangle bic and this
r which we didn't label that r right
over there is the altitude of triangle a
i b
and we know and and so we could find the
area of each of those triangles in terms
of both r and their bases and maybe if
we sum up the area of all the triangles
we can get something in terms of our
perimeter and our n radius so let's just
try to do this so the area of the entire
triangle the area of abc
is going to be equal to and i'll color
code this it's going to be equal to the
area of a
ic so that's what i'm shading here in
magenta
it's going to be equal to the area of a
ic
plus the area
of bic which is this triangle right over
here actually let me do that in a
different color i've already used the
blue
so let me do that in orange plus the
area of
bic
so that's this area right over here
so plus the area of bic
and then finally plus the area i'll do
this in a
let's see i'll use this pink color plus
the area of aib
plus the area of aib that is the area
a i
b if you take the sum of the areas of
these three triangles you've got the
area of the larger triangle now aic the
area of aic is going to be equal to
one-half base times height so this is
going to be one-half
the base is the length of ac one-half ac
times the height times this altitude
right over here which is just going to
be r times r that's the area of aic and
then the area of bic b i c is going to
be one half
one half the base which is bc
times the height which is r
and then plus
the area of a i b this one over here is
going to be one half the base which is
the length of this side a b
a b
times the height which is once again
which is once again r and over here we
can factor out a one-half r from all of
these terms and you get one-half r
times
times ac
plus bc
plus b c
plus a b
and i think you see where this is going
plus that's a different shade of pink
plus a b
plus
a b
now what is ac plus b c plus a b a c
plus b c
plus a b well that's going to be the
perimeter p
that
is the perimeter of p if you just take
the sum of the sides so that is the
perimeter of p and it looks like we're
done the area
of our triangle the area of our triangle
of abc
is equal to one-half times r
times the perimeter times the perimeter
which is kind of a neat result one half
times the in radius times the perimeter
of the triangle or sometimes you'll see
it written like this it's equal to r
times p over s
or sorry p over 2
p over 2 and this term right over here
the perimeter divided by 2 is sometimes
called the semi perimeter
semi
semi perimeter
semi perimeter and sometimes it's
denoted by s so sometimes you'll see the
area is equal to r times s
where s is the semi perimeter it's the
perimeter divided by 2. i personally
like it this way a little bit more
because i remember that p is perimeter
this is useful because obviously now if
someone gives you an in radius and a
perimeter you can figure out the area of
a triangle or if someone gives you the
area of the triangle and the perimeter
you can get the n radius so if they give
you two of the of these variables you
can always get the third so for example
if someone if this was a triangle right
over here this is maybe the most famous
of the right triangles
if i have a triangle that has lengths
three four and five we know this is a
right triangle you can verify this from
the pythagorean theorem and if somewhere
say what is the in radius of this
triangle right over here well we can
figure out the area pretty pretty easily
we know this is a right triangle 3
squared plus 4 squared is equal to 5
squared so the area is going to be
area is going to be equal to 3 times 4
times 1 half so 3 times 4 times 1 half
is 6 and then the perimeter here is
going to be equal to 3 plus 4 which is 7
plus 5 is 12. and so we have
we have the area so let's write this
area
is equal to
one-half times the n radius times the
perimeter so here we have 12 is equal to
perimeter so we have oh sorry we have
six let me write this in the area is 6.
we have 6 is equal to 1 half times the
inner radius times 12. and so in this
situation one half times 12 is just 6.
you have 6 is equal to 6r divide both
sides by 6 you get r is equal to 1. so
if you were to draw the n radius for
this one which is kind of a neat result
so let me draw some
angle bisectors here
draw some angle bisectors here this 3 4
5 right triangle has an n radius of one
so this distance equals this distance
which is equal this distance which is
equal
which is equal to
which is equal to one which is kind of a
neat result